here we go three two one extra hold on
everybody
shang chi is at its core a marvel movie
that comes with the promise
of action and a certain promise to the
quality of the sequences that we're
about to deliver this film will take
your breath away on the big screen and
it is as big as anything that we've ever
brought to life in the mcu before
with the best sequence everything had to
be perfect
that was something i've never done
before taking a bus down san francisco
hills and crashing into
real cars
we are using literally every single inch
of that bus and figuring out what we can
do with it
we make a good team
some days at work are harder than others
we're working with world-class stunt
teams their work ethic everything that
they're doing is like incredible to
witness i was training with the world
champion of tai chi and she was
absolutely amazing
i took two weeks to rehearse the fight
sequence it's a symbol of the
aggressiveness and anger of the
character
we're going to incorporate a lot of
different styles of martial arts tai chi
which is very very flowy another one is
wing chun which is a bit more combative
and then looking at certain regional
styles that kind of fill in this mosaic
of how this character moves
this film should stand out on its own
it's got a very magical story behind it
mixed with a lot of action
the world has no idea what they're up
for it's time for you to take your place
by my side that's not going to happen
you